there you go concerts might be on pause
but you can still get the rock star
treatment
jc fernandez is live at the hard rock
cafe on the strip with details on their
backstage experience hey jc
hey mercedes and rocky this is so cool
this exclusive tour happens on
sundays and mondays and this is jason
lent he is a rock
historian and we are in the beatles room
exclusive room that you'll see on the
tour
and some really neat items let's start
with this one right here jason this is
one of ringo
starr suits he joined the band actually
they already had a drummer and they
needed
a replacement drummer as they were
leaving for a tour he jumped in
not a bad career move if you ask me pete
best was the one that left the beatles
you
talk about the decision the guy regrets
and ringo starr steps in this here is
such a cool little piece of history you
guys
you can feel the reverberations come off
this this is a piece of the original
cavern club stage in liverpool
the beatles play 292 shows
on that stage so when they tore the club
down we were able to get some pieces of
the stage and
you have to preserve this history and
not only the beatles but rolling stones
played there
and queen all those icons touch that
wood right there
this looks like a letter handwritten
letter what's the backstory on the
letter this i love this piece
because it shows the beatles were just
fun guys this is a letter george
harrison wrote
to a fan back in liverpool the band was
in hamburg germany
he needed his car washed he was the
first bill to own a car so
he asked susan question mark to wash his
car he gave very detailed numbered
instructions
and at the end he said hey go ahead and
take that muddy greasy dirty water over
to 24th land road
throw it all over the new four there
that was paul mccartney's new car
these are just having fun these are some
of the facts you're gonna get lance
let's go over here these are some of the
facts you're gonna get from jason when
you do the tour here at the hard rock
cafe the backstage tour
last item less than 30 seconds what are
we looking at on the wall
this is truly special this is one of
john london's guitar straps
and back then anything john lennon
wanted he would get from the
manufacturers
he wanted a snakeskin guitar strap
unfortunately they didn't make those
so vox went hand designed doesn't look
like that using metal that is such a
neat story so many cool items and we
have so much more to show you guys in
the four o'clock hour
including we have john lennon's glasses
we're going to show you plus we're going
to show you some of the great food you
get in your backstage tour
we'll send it back to you guys in the
studio that's cool it's like his sin
city chronicles
so great lots of history right there
thanks jc i